yes we did cuz we back at it again it's
the fighter in the kid this is really
the fighter in the kid come on
baby miss you buddy miss you I feel like
we haven't seen each other in a while we
talked a little bit uh we didn't really
we got catch coming down 2023 is
cominging down 2023 is coming down had
an amazing weekend in spaan one of the
best spots off the hook in Naples which
I should just get a house there uh this
weekend if you could afford it n $8
million you can buy a house for million
when you walk to the beach you see the
houses you're like this is oh no it's
it's so stupid everyone's so old though
get I mean old and conservative for me
it'd be tough for you you
know right no don't say that like Naples
is a good market for no no come on uh
there are there is some gray hair in my
Spokan I had a lot of gray hair in the
crowd yeah my my my fans are older
they're growing up with you they're
growing up with me I love it um and same
thing Naples is always going to have
older people like in the pandemic there
were old people with noples has always
been old though that's what it is always
but I feel yeah 2023 is coming to an end
you don't hear a lot of uh excitement
for 2024 2023 was tough this a I mean we
got to figure out our our schedule as
far as shop Show Goes we did our last
one today because Christmas is next
Monday I know I think we take a we we'll
do Wednesday and then we'll take that
week off yeah cuz I'm going to be in uh
I'm I'm going to be in Florida anyway
I'm going to go then to Charlotte I got
to do Charlotte okay too much right um
yeah Charlotte uh Comedy Zone so we'll
just have one yeah and then the holidays
yeah we take the holidays off like like
uh civilized human so no Wednesday like
next week or just no he's saying
Wednesday next week W that's it no
Monday we'll do Wednesday and then
that's it till oh so so January 1 week
so we'll take a week off so it'll be
Wednesday when this Wednesday is our
last thing and then we won't do another
one until what the following Wednesday I
guess or or yeah the following Wednesday
makes sense no that's when Christmas is
isn't it so no look the count right
there Christmas is next Monday so
Wednesday would be the 27th so we're
good there uh no I won't be able to make
that I don't I could I could but but
that's but then I have to come back and
then I have to go right back to charlot
though and then this Wednesday are we
good I can do it if we have to no you
don't don't worry about flying back then
um so we would be so this will be our
last one till the third
yeah
so not this one we're going to do one on
Wednesday aren't we this Wednesday yes
yeah yeah my bet so it's this week next
week off yeah and then come back
Christmas week off good come back fired
up come back with some stor fired up now
let me ask you a couple questions can we
talk about the fights you probably
already talked about it with the shop
show can we get yeah but we can get into
it well I just want to get your take on
Ian Gary I I was very disappointed he
got pneumonia pneumonia pneumonia got
pneumonia his kids have it yeah but they
resched uh fighting March 6 in Miami
against uh Jeff Neil okay so that's good
I think this is a good thing for him let
let all the toxic all well pressure
forget about being sick all the
negativity no I'm saying that that
pressure caus him probably to get sick
right maybe who knows like things happen
but just let it let all the hate like
the the MMA fan base is fial they'll
move on to somebody else they yeah so by
the time March comes some people still
stay on it but it'll be better you can
focus on fighting like that's God give
uh you know Mulligan there
100% uh Jeff Neil uh is an easier
opponent than luk or no different tough
Jeff's [__] they were supposed to
fight originally and then Jeff got hurt
that's when he made the that's when his
wife made the uh the mug shot shirt MH
but Jeff's tough man they're both tough
fights and Jeff is ranked so it's good
for
him um and he he beat vente luk so yeah
all right well here we go yeah here we
go that'll be exciting I was saying on
the shop show like this that last week
that UFC 296 the whole thing was like
dark I agree the trash the Ian Gary
stuff is whatever that's funny you know
that is what it is but then with Leon's
dead Dad yeah uh you know strickling and
dupes fighting in the crowd what was
that about the Trump stuff so so my my
thing is this with the uh I would only
say this about the um Co Kobe cumington
it's important to understand the
difference right between trash talk
that's good Larry Bird muham Ali great
and even if you want to [__] with
somebody's girl or their dad you can say
it to them secretly on the court or
whatever it is to me it's when you start
usually no matter what the sport that's
off limit I agree with you like I don't
think it makes the sport better I don't
think it makes you better and it's not
funny it just makes you it kind of just
makes you feel kind of like oh it's dark
like like when I'm laughing when Conor
McGregor goes who the [__] is that guy
or I'd like to take this moment to
apologize to absolutely [__] no one
all this is all a side effect of the
this is the Conor the khabib thing well
the the Connor thing he's done it
multiple times he goes a little too much
but it's Connor and he became the most
paid athlete of all time people are
trying to follow that that's all this is
just a [__] wave of you're not Conor you
don't you you don't have the wit the
humor the intelligence the skill so
you're not Conor but the UFC the same
way social media Advocates hate the UFC
Advocates that they want that but there
there's only you can't replicate that
age so all the is is it's der it's
called derivative it's a derivative it's
like you are you're like the truck
version yeah it's a product it's a
product of that where they go well I I
want Conor's money I want his Fame right
and so they see his formula but it he's
he can't duplicate that so you just and
the UFC Advocates it because they like
it it's like it's like with dupes and
Strickland fighting and Dan goes I can't
believe I I sat him that close and he
has to play that character he knows what
he's doing oh there's cameras on it they
and then they'll use that to Hype up the
fight like this is all planned all this
is an agenda yes Trump being there
Tucker Carlson be there Kobe getting a
title shot all this is precon all this
is an agenda all of this none of this
happens by coincidence yes now they're
not telling Strickland hey make sure you
beat up D Poli he's behind you in the St
no no but what they're doing is you're
creating perfect environment for that to
happen and then going oh my God these
guys you can't be doing this this is
insane play it play it oh you know what
dude I mean that's the way they sat them
there come on you're 100% right and
Dana's in charge of the seating he goes
I just made a mistake I can't I'm an
idiot and people it's okay oh now she he
tells he says uh move out of the way
yeah he tells comes out him like this
yeah and and by the way he knows what
he's doing he's not hurting his hand
he's just using his forearm They're just
causing some problems there but all this
is planned all the as far as like the
UFC like they have cameras on it they
even had bodyguards right there that's
good yeah it's all it's all planned now
now um but but but back to Colby he
talked trash this way and I think he was
he was going to do whatever it took to
get Leon to fight emotional he knew this
was the trigger he could push the button
he could push I think he went through
Camp it was like holy [__] man I'm
getting older I don't his team's like
dude you're not moving the same even
your cardio is not as good you you look
a little stiff dude he's like man if
Leon sits we're going to get picked
apart well we we got to get a reaction
get him fight
emotional very interesting I never so
he's like let's get Leon emotional no
one's ever talk [__] about his dad his
dead Dad let's get him a fight emotional
people are going to hate you but it's
the only way you're going to win I think
do you think his Camp actually said that
to him um I think he I think he came up
with the idea and the Camp's like it's
not bad cuz if the plan is to you sit on
the outside cuz you don't move like you
used to you're this you're just going to
be an awful night in the office right so
I think Kobe's like [__] I don't care
surpr see him he just didn't look like
the he just first of all father time is
it father time though or is it I stepped
over the line I know it inherently and I
feel I feel a little off about God no
Kobe doubled down on it after the fight
yeah no that's not Kobe no no he he
wasn't moving like usually it's two
years off ask you this question two
years off at his age and then you're
fighting for the title it's an issue
it's an issue but isn't there also the
idea that like maybe those comments
aren't actually Colby they are a
character he's playing and I have a
philosophy on that which is as you get
older and you keep playing that
character it feels more and more like a
lie it's pushed it's I can hear it maybe
because I'm a performer and I've been
doing this a long time I can hear the
the push in his voice a little bit it's
a subtle thing you might be able to you
know you kind of go you're you're kind
of like saying this stuff like about his
dad it doesn't seem authentic it's like
you're pushing this character of the
heel but I'm starting to feel like
that's not actually who you are and and
and I don't think it is him actually I
don't think ultim I don't know the guy
used to not to but then when you double
down on it and then you just lose the
biggest fight of your life and the first
thing you get on the mic and you're
thinking Trump and talking about the
Border crisis it's like where's your
priorities at right now also what are
you you're a politician now like what do
you know about this stuff all this all
this is orchestrated all you think Trump
just called Dan up Thursday night was
like Hey I'm going be in Vegas it's all
about elections it's all about about
that fan base they they they they play
walk out music when Trump walks into the
arena listen I'm not saying I'm not a
trump guy but it's all that's what I'm
like when they're forced on me like oh
dude you have Tucker Carlson there you
have Kid Rock there playing walk out me
crowd's going nuts yeah Kobe didn't
deserve a title shot this is all
orchestrated this is WWE UFC meets you
know the all this is this is whole
agenda the whole agenda of political
agenda for Trump and then you get you
get Kobe I got you nobody's closer to
Donald Trump than Dana White they are
two PS in a pot he Dana has all this
access to all these young minds MH and
all this influence
it puts makes Trump look cool you know
even if you hate Kobe he's still there
look what they're do the UFC's they're
the best at it as far as Markin look at
the crowd when when the two fighters
about to face off after Bruce Buffer you
see them like this yeah one side it's
all media the older heads the the guys
who've been doing it for Damon Martin
all the old heads or all they're typing
on their computers they go to the other
side it's all ticktockers it's all
Comics ticktockers influen people who
post the fights oh wow it's just all
Market it's just a [__] storm to keep
them in the spotlight W smart so
nothing's an accident whether whether
these guys know it or not there's a
reason you're there oh makes it the
hippest show on it makes it the hippest
party in town Jared Leto yeah all these
guys Tu car Kid Rock yeah Mario Lopez
it's the thing boxing doesn't do this
anymore no it's all the biggest
ticktockers and they have you know they
they have the kid the nek boys that like
all this all it's all an agenda M and
there's nothing wrong with it business
is a booming it's a booming I'll do the
exact same thing but figure it out guys
this is all planned where where does
Colby Go From Here does he fight Ian
Gary does he fight what happens here
um it's a good question he called for
Stephen he called for Wonder Boy we'll
see if they do that it depends what the
UFC wants to do with him it also if you
go to because Kobe's not getting another
title shot it's not happening he's had
three he's 0 and three so this one was
four so they're going to put him back of
the line so if you go to Colby at his
age after that performance looked a
little rusty right okay here's shot
here's Ian Gary like the young up in
commer but look look at the waves so you
have Shawn Brady there you have shovot
you have Bal muhamad godam you know you
got you got these Savages coming through
Ian Machado Gary JDM fighting soon Kevin
holl go ahead enjoy that you know and
then then you also got Michael Venom
paage in the division now so Kobe goes
yeah hey bud you're probably going to
have to win four in order to get you
have to be undeniable he beat shot hell
no he beat D Gary gonna be tough yeah
Shan Brady tough fight for him yeah sea
Brady's a monster JDM Savage so it's
it's the young gu's turn now so UFC got
what they wanted all right Trump's
elections coming up you you carried the
flag thank you for that you be hated for
the rest of your life but still you got
paid thank you sir now it's now let the
real boys get to get to work you should
have been in the first place but it's
all an agenda it's all pushing and I'm
not saying there anything wrong with it
I'm just saying figure it
out yeah that was uh that was really cuz
I we'd be singing a different tune if
they're doing this for
Biden completely different if Biden was
K signing he was like you know yeah I
know he mumbles but you
know Kamal Harris is the best we've ever
had you know he don't know where he's
at could have Biden walk to the ring
yeah yeah can't have him walk him out
nothing K what do you think of the fight
but that that demo goes with the right
demo like there there's a peanut butter
and jelly that's all it is yeah again
nothing wrong I'm not saying there's
anything wrong with it I'm just saying
figure it out all this an agenda yeah it
was a it was clumsy but but all of it's
clumsy that's my point all this is
Clumsy and you're you're taking the
sport out of the UFC now it's becoming
very WWE I would agree cuz and we'll see
what they do next bah Muhammad deserves
the title shot 100 he should have had it
this time he didn't we got this product
so again that's going to be interesting
what's your thought on that with balal
and good fight yeah Leon look's so good
though man Le Leon's a Savage Leon's a
Savage yeah he is a Savage you watch
Patty pilet Tony Ferguson I did tough
tough tough no no win situation for
Patty I thought he handled it great yeah
he did again remember Patty was e in
Gary before he in Gary yeah cuz Patty
was so hated he's beloved just like y
got all the hate after that that uh
Jared Gordon fight thought he you know
he thought he won asking for bonus and
bar stooled all that people hated him Y
and then next wave comes along now see
and Gary so Patty what what happened
long layoff took a year off hasn't
fought since last year December he got
gas takes a year he always does but
takes a year off we forget about it you
see him like I like this guy wins the
fight he's humble about it Tony's a
warrior perfect y now we're back on the
Patty train that's how this goes yep
what do you think is next for Tony
though um the thing and I know Bron say
retired everyone here say retire we want
to see him stop here's my problem when
people say this that have never fought
have never competed at a high level when
you say stop when you say this guy needs
to retired Dana needs to cut this guy
okay are you going to pay his bills
who's paying his Mortgage in here who's
paying that's not a good argument
terrible AR who's feing his kids
terrible argument Bubba all right no
it's not terrible I understand what
you're saying let me ask you me yes it
is it's no different there's a reason
you have a commission that says you're
not you're not forget commission they
just they just s just sanction slap I
would say I would say I would say you're
talking about brain damage on that level
to me I'm like I don't it it's not it's
not a fighter will die in that ring you
could let Fighters fight they'd be there
Fighters that would fight until they
were 60 that is not the criteria and
that is not who makes the call you have
a medical establishment you have
commission you have well in boxing you
have it you can't get cleared for
certain things you can't but in the UFC
who is it it's the commission that just
SL but there's not so that so your
argument's out it's not out argument say
should be my argument is should be like
but they should be paid know that there
is there is a he had a a storied amazing
career I don't think it serves the sport
it definitely doesn't serve him or any
other future Fighters when we just C
keep watching somebody take more and
more damage because what happens is now
it's spectal B we all we all agree with
this he should stop fighting my answer
for you how's he going to make well you
could ask that question about
anybody right I mean how is he going to
make money I mean you could say that
about a lot of people you can't say
professional the only way he's going to
make money is that you could say that
about a lot of football players that
retire right I mean here no here's the
difference terrible argument football
they split the revenue 5050 UFC splits
it 14% but but that's fighting they're
not paid but it's not but see it's
fighting I could have said that to any I
could say that about any fighter
literally I could say that about 90% of
the fighters in the UFC what are they
going to do now I can promise you should
this is the problem they should be
compensated so then let's talk about a
pension plan let's talk about things
like that Tony doesn't have that right
now so when everybody in here says has
stop fighting my question is how is he
going to pay his mortgage but that's not
a I'm not I'm not I'm I'm saying he
should stop fighting that's a good
argument we we don't know his financials
I know he has a family I know he has a
mortgage I know he has car payments I
know he has to feed the kids I know has
to pay for the school so it's easy for
us in here to go stop fighting I'm going
to tell you this he's going to you you
could say that about him at any time at
any point right so he could have four
more fights he's still going to have
that question and and my feeling is that
he's going to be able to answer that
question and he'll have a life after
fighting the sooner he stops if he keeps
going he may be eaten out of a straw and
then he really has no future so we
that's my issue is that when you see
somebody taking the kind of damage that
people have taken you have to think
about their future and and so so with
the same argument I said Fighters don't
think about their future yeah but we
have to are the audience the the the the
people that watch it the people that
watch it I know but they're not you
don't have to cover his nut then then
call for then call for pay yes and
that's what and pension and that's what
they're fighting for so at Tony's level
you're talking about one of the best
155s of all time in any other sport he
can retire comfortably and right off
that's my biggest problem with the [__]
the only reason he's fighting is cuz he
has a family in a nut and people go you
got to retire move on cool do you have a
a job for him you're right who has the
job for him so he can cover his food for
his kids otherwise I if I'm Tony or I
didn't have what I'm doing I'm I'm
taking that be knuckle 100% 100% UFC
doesn't have like a pension like the NFL
they have nothing and that's why there's
this H Legends Legends who are broke Man
Legends who have they they nothing they
have nothing so for a guy like Tony
again we can all say he needs to stop
Tony's like where am I going to make
100K what job do you want me to do to
make my nut every month have to $10,000
yeah oh but go work at the UFC gym I get
I make $330,000 a year doing I can't I
can't afford my life what am I going to
do but you need to stop okay or I can
just take some and it sucks but this is
what it is or I can just take a fight
I'll be a huge Underdog I'll get [__]
up but I feed my family and my my kids
100% 100% and you're right you we need
it there has to be some kind of a
[__] some kind of a pension or
something when you fought that long yeah
when you fought that [__] long and
left that much of your literally that
much of your body in the ring and they
leave their body in the [__] ring
they leave their brains in the ring and
and and and that's it see you thanks a
lot like sail off into the sunset with
nothing dude
nothing you know I don't do we all want
does everybody want to watch a fight
like a sport like that does it make you
feel good nobody cares I do yeah but
there there's yeah but we you still
watch it
but when you have a guy what kind of a
win streak was Tony on one of the best
to ever do it Tony like 12 in a row one
of the best to ever do it when he was
when he was the Boogey Man could before
he blews me out and and and and it's
like see you later look at that [__]
look at how hard that is wow so hard to
do so hard to do is that 12 yeah 12
right and like all fighters there's that
there's that thing that happens right
you saw it with Colby you see it with
Tony with Justin you know look at that
and remember Tony's fighting before the
cool Tik Tok days and making money off
twitch and all he's an OG yeah so he
doesn't have those business you know
aspirations like these other guys he's
old school super old school Ultimate
Fighter yeah old school man old school
so the patties of the world the sugar
Shan they're good they don't have to
fight Tony's older man he doesn't have
those same Avenues everyone stop
fighting them he's like [__] that suck
and here's the other thing you you might
want to be kept from the UFC beer
knuckle is going to sign Tony so would
you rather see him in beer knuckle no
again that's the only way he can make
that lump sum of money to cover his
nut that's how this goes it sucks it's
the dirtiest sport in the world it sucks
I love it it's so dirty it's so dark
well you I love it I don't like that but
I love it yeah right but here's the
thing nobody going to do
[__] every's going keep watching where's
Brian Ortega man he was hurt yeah he's
coming
back
but yeah that's the nature of the sport
but I I just I don't condone when
everyone goes ah he needs to get cut he
can't fight anymore it's like cool you
have a job for
him well you help his kids eat at night
I still think he's got a better future
when he stops fighting I mean the
early ear right that's what I mean you
don't sign up for [__] UFC cuz you're
worried about well he man will die for
his family in that [__] ring yes
he'll die for his family and he'll keep
fighting and that's what he has to do
yeah ain't that a [__] yeah it's a
[__] it's a real [__]
when you're watching that all this is
how it ends for everybody unless you're
Conor McGregor that's exactly right
every single fighter you see this is how
it ends this is why that lawsuit so
important this is how it goes we all
watch it we're all here for the circus
that's why we even with the inan Gary
stuff okay you want to ruin this young
kid's whole [__] thing it's
unbelievable what's the point what is
the point what do you want them you want
the kid to grow up in a broken home what
are you doing like give me a [__]
break people don't think people people
suck dude they suck Savages man that
Bryce Mitchell Josh EMT knockout was
hard to watch awful yeah and Bryce took
that fight uh yeah awful matchup for him
could couldn't be a worse match up just
cuz em impossible to take down he hits
like a MC truck Bryce Mitchell has no
striking has to engage with yeah it's
tough when you're so onedimensional it's
it gets tough man stay in age that was a
flatline UFC shows UFC shows him you
know thing yeah what's your take on
that that's their
audience yeah some the audience loves
that Kobe they go like people love when
Sean Strickland does this stuff people
that jumped in the stands and the the
[__] he talks and it brings it down
doesn't
it people like this toxic Strickland you
know doing that to me is like a little
different that's the drama that's like
do you know the background on Strickland
no his childhood he got he was abused by
his father he'll talk about it you need
to hit your kids more like you know it's
a dark it's dark gave his dad a gun to
commit suicide you know it's all dark
yeah it's dark it was
dark uh and and I think that there's so
if you look at like Ali if you look at
uh any of the greats if you look at
Larry Bird if you look at Michael Jordan
look these guys were competitors at the
highest level they talk trash and
everything else it was always classy
though they kept it classy there is a
there's something that's why there's
something called sportsmanlike conduct
and you have it in football when you hit
somebody in football you get fined you
get in real trouble the NFLs run that
way and it makes the sport actually
better I think it makes it more it does
though it does you have to have
standards you have to have class hitting
because the NFL you got to realize I'm
saying un when they say ons spoken like
conduct that's when those big hits or
they hit the I'm talking about complet
different I'm talking when you hit some
no no I'm talking about when somebody
you hit somebody after I'm not talking
about pampering the quarterback I'm
talking about like in the NFL if you hit
somebody after the play or you stomp on
somebody these foot they're like get the
hey he he everybody's like no well no
because it hurts the team you get a
penalty but it also brings the sport we
don't want that in the sport we don't
want it but if it happens you [__] over
your team you're probably not going to
beat the Dallas Cowboys or buff bills
cool I understand that the issue with
this is what repercussions happened to
drus Dy and Sean Strickland nothing
right there's no there's no
repercussions right there's oh matter of
fact you probably get a bigger bonus
that's right yeah now part of it is
fight
part of it is you know this is a raw
form of sport in a sense it's like the
original sport it's like two guys in
their underwear and it is supposed to
have an element of savagery you could
make that argument because it's like
actual combat but I do think that you
know boxing doesn't have that boxing's
vicious they talk trash they go out but
the greatest trash doctor Muhammad Ali
never did that stuff you know so you got
to just be careful here here you put
your business hat on your Dana White
how's boxing doing mikee Tyson was
pretty dead bu I wonder if I don't think
dead but it's it's compared to the UFC
yeah the UFC is not even close but I
don't I don't know that I don't know
that the the again I think Trash Talk
Trash Talk
Works trash talk is there's a line yeah
trash Talk's great for the most part
guys don't cross that line to be honest
like you have a few HBY did his thing
which I told I he did it cuz it was a
desperation move I didn't think he was
older he needs to get on out of his his
game to pressure forward and you know he
knew he was going to be hated for it and
that was his only that was his hell Mary
didn't work no did not work yeah
Sportsman like you you still want to be
Sportsman likee I I most part guys are
and then the culture of the MMA is what
makes it for guys to jump on Ian gar
it's the cool thing to do jump on me or
Patty Pim it becomes the cool thing like
it's a it's it's the bully syndrome
where everyone's like all right let's
pick on that kid he's an easy target
there's a lot to pick Gladiator so they
all get involved then becomes this this
[__] storm yeah just all they do
laughing with blood in your mouth you
know and and I so part of what we love
is when two guys go at it they they
trash talk then they fight like a they
crush each other but like even with even
with Colby and and and Usman you know
what I liked after that fight what' they
do they hugged after that fight they
went you know I had to sell the fight
right that's I knew you know yeah and
that's fine cuz he wasn't talking trash
like this
he to separate him you're not cool you
can't talk [__] about someone's dead dad
what that was my problem with Connor
when he did that with with khabib about
his dad and actually put his dad in and
other people in actual questionable
political turmoil with Putin and stuff
it was weird he he was really really
pushing the line I didn't respect that
and then when he says to uh to [__]
uh he gets his leg broken Dustin PO he
goes your wife slid into my DMs like
come on dude you lost already just relax
you know what are you doing you're crazy
just lose you're feeling out the line
yeah they're losing their sense of self
they're trying to figure out what the
line is they find out the hard way there
you go people go oh we're not board with
this my bad all right that's the line my
bad I would even make the argument like
when you see people go to that line how
does it work out for them like in a lot
of it's never worked out for anybody has
right never works out for them Connor
with Aldo it worked out but outside that
yeah but even with Aldo was great
because he was like I'm your daddy he
was coming at him right he coming out
pretty hardore but again he did that
take a page out of Kobe's book he did it
to get Aldo to fight emot
and forget about the G storm forward so
he could was crazy trash talker but it
was always about him he was always like
you know he he skated the line but he
was great yeah cha is great he was a
little different but again it's the
culture it's the Tik Tock like the Logan
Pauls of the world these these kids
young there's no yeah what this can get
me views yeah isn't it isn't it older
people's job though to at least say uh
there's a reason let me hey young guys
can I tell you why that's bad you know
whose job it is who's the UFC's well you
know why cuz they're older when they
have that of course it's it's the UFC
it's Dana White it's the brass when they
have that meeting that annual Summit
100% at Red Rocks they go real quick
fellas this is you're going to get fine
$10,000 if you talk about somebody's
dead Dad if you do this this these are
the guidelines we can't have it ex
exactly but they make money off of it so
they do have it I don't respect it
that's why people tune in the that's
what
sucks
well it's not you just said it yeah you
just [__] said it that that NFL has
that 100% NBA adults in the room the
adults in the room the successful people
in the roomy fellas we were all idiots
when we were young men all idiots
okay you're letting the inmates run the
Asylum exactly so of course they're
going to pop off and then when you
encourage it or a guy gets a main event
next or a guy gets booked on a major
card next they go oh man that guy went
really dark but he's getting applauded
for he's getting money for it so they go
that's what I have to do UFC is
rewarding this Behavior even in the
animal kingdom when they when they when
the poachers would come in and kill the
big male elephants and take their tusks
they had the longest tusks what would
happen is the Adolescent males would
they didn't grow up with the big males
telling them how to behave so they would
start bullying everybody and like Goring
the older females no and the entire
structure broke down y gangas Khan when
gangis Khan was taking over the world
the young boys would follow they would
watch the older men so they could learn
how to be Warriors but the younger boys
would watch the older boys come in rape
kill just indiscriminately take [__]
right guess what happened those younger
boys would go back to the camps and they
would do that to the women in their Camp
they would turn on the they would like
well what that's how we act that's how
my [__] brother does that my my dad
does it what's with it so then they'd
see a girl over there and they'd rape
her and then gangs con and the top said
the Mongols were like we can't have this
we're actually having we're having we
have to establish rules we have to estab
so what he would do then is he'd say now
okay what we're going to do is send a
scout out and say look if you if you do
what we say and let us come through and
feed us and let us take over you can
keep everything the way it is if you
fight us we're going to [__] level
you yeah but it he even the Mongols had
to figure out Savages yeah cuz that [__]
that [__] will be a snake eating its own
tail and that that was my argument with
Kobe and all that be yeah was rough um
and then to perform that way it's rough
yep shav cot Rock monov uh serious uh
now he actually he grappled so much and
people were surprised because uh he had
an injury going into that he did yeah
really bad ankle injury oh [__] but he
he's the next like guy 180 18 finishes
he's the next guy monster he's the guy I
think Wonder Boy what 41 41 he had Jack
Black walk him out great really yeah I
didn't see that part what a great career
oh yeah one of the best he never get oh
yeah he hasn't taken that much damage
yeah or n yeah he has but one or two
more he has one or two more at he'll be
41 um soon 41 it's tough man the other
thing too for you got to decide and he
has other he has his family owns the
biggest karate school in South Carolina
like he's set financially but you're not
fighting for titles anymore like those
days are done Kobe not fighting for
titles anymore so why do you do it you
know yeah that's that good Point yeah
you get addicted to the you don't want
to be just you you don't want to keep
doing it just to be a guy no one started
just to be a guy that's why I got out
you don't want to be just a guy no once
you realize you're get out of there man
cuz the only way you're making legit
money is being a champ right just being
a guy is never good yeah I'd love to see
Wonder Boy fight MVP if he makes it
through Kevin holl be great that be awes
that's a great move that'd be cool I
think he has one a really cool fight
that's a good call I'd like to see that
how old is Michael vom page he's up
there now he was so stupid
good might be
36 still got some fighting
him has he lost the step or is he just
his we'll see yeah cuz he's over in
Bellator we don't know this is a
different game ain't it different game
they're G him a you know a fair match up
with Kevin Holland then after this I
remember that fight with Lima o that
guy's such a killer um and for Patty
piml now the UFC's done their job now
it's time to take the MS off now you
have to fight some guys now got to fight
some guys yeah fight some
guys they they they they just do he's
got he's such a draw that they they're
they don't want to put him in with they
are now like you can only cuddle a guy
for so long Tony feron younger guy for
who Patty yeah it's going be a top 15
guy because it's time to [__] her get
off the pot I'll tell you who they
better [__] not toss him
I'll tell you right now who they better
not give Patty piml I'll tell you
[__] right now he's ranked number 12
they call him BS BSD I call him BDSM
it's benois St Denise I swear to God if
they give Patty benois I'm gonna freak
the [__] out why this guy he's a special
forces guy in France he's the scariest
[__] thing you've ever seen in the
UFC this Hamza looks like a a cuddly
bear next this guy is such a Savage look
at his he's a special forces guy too mhm
oh yeah his nickname's the God of War it
looks like he's taking a coffee break
when he's down octagon he's such a
problem he if they give [__] Patty
this guy know this the UFC is done with
Patty binlet really you gotta watch him
fight fought our boy Bo fora last time
and it was a [__] nightmare wait what
what was he doing what was he he knocked
out our boy Matt steam Rolla for Ola
with a KO head
kick he's such a
problem it's so rude how good he is and
he's
12 go back to go back the lightweight
and he's just a he he'd just be that's a
long long night for our boy I mean he
could compete in the top three right now
so the UFC just trying to get him more
FaceTime before he steamrolls through
whoever he's such a problem is he a
contender he's 12 what do they have him
at they have him at 12 12 okay okay
these poor guys that have to fight him
he does everything right and and doesn't
break a sweat he doesn't get excited
interviews Commando right he kills
people
dude if they dude I swear to God if they
give Patty him I'm gonna freak out
that's so
rude I don't know who no and notice no
you've never heard him nobody's talking
[__] to him no oh everyone was oh it's
one of those you know oh and he's he's
not like H guys are above theame he's
not hot talking [__] all right he's
probably on a mission right now he's
probably killing people in Ukraine or
something like that right and he's like
got a match up he's like cool just tell
somebody else he's can I see what he is
in the in the French military is he uh
he doesn't talk about it
yes he doesn't talk about [__] IA I
probably just introduced you your
favorite fighter yeah first Marine
infantry paratrooper French army Special
Forces command served in mly during the
war West Africa the nation gratitude
hold on hold up served in uh West Africa
fighting terrorist groups you think he's
scared of maacha
yeah no he's uh that guy is one of those
special dudes yeah with his [__]
beard just award the medal of Nations
gratitude comant cross he's a Savage
yeah he's got he's got some [__] going
on fought at
middleweight yeah and he seems to he
seems to be he seems to have a um broad
knowledge of fighting in general nogee
you know wrestling French kickboxing all
that
stuff he's a he's a
problem yeah he's a problem he's a
problem yeah he's been doing
it Ben sandini let me
see who's that is that his lady it's got
to be your wife
yeah wow there he
is good luck good luck huh yeah you
don't good Lu look at him look at him
yeah that that guy and look at the guys
their faces are block blocked out yeah
dude if you have a picture we got to
block out your friend's faces killing
terrorists yeah that's doing your job
lot of in going on to the entire
division good
luck I sound like the bad guy from Taken
good good luck luck good luck have a set
of skills I will find you good luck oh
boy he finds him doesn't he yep yep
every time every time all three all
three
movies unreal yeah he might be your
favorite fighter now yep he certainly is
you you jack off the Special Forces Guys
these guys got some hairy chests
oh come on no is that Russian Patty yeah
do you like that SAS I mean I you don't
mind it I mean no you don't mind a hairy
man what if it was a little heart he's
not too bad no yeah he's not he's not
like no he's not not he's not like
orlovski or some [__] yeah but it's good
you got to have a little hair on your
chest so how does he transition from
Special Forces into I'm just going to do
UFC well he's always been training
probably hand toand combat yeah and then
mentality wise good luck breaking that
guy yeah right oh yeah I didn't think
you can just stay uncomfortable for a
much longer time than most people I bet
trash talking doesn't affect him either
no I was talking I was talking to a
couple of those guys and I was like this
Delta guy I was talking to I go what
what is it about that that you're able
to what do you think is the thing he
goes I think it's
just it's like you're just as cold you
get cold you get hungry but if some
people are able to just stay
uncomfortable for a longer period of
time it's like I'm just going to be
uncomfortable for three months and
you're going to break after the first
two hours I was like all right
yeah the two factors that they the way
they get guys like that the way you make
it into that kind of unit are two things
sleep deprivation and the cold you can
break Men by all you have to do is you
want to find the toughest guys in the
group you reduce their sleep and you get
them cold and and there's guys like I
personally I do not have the
Constitution to be I can deal with sleep
deprivation but if you make me cold I am
a [__] I can't keep heat in my body my
neck is too [__] long you're just not
buil for I don't have a chest the whole
thing right you're just not don't do
that don't hey the whole hey the whole
get up don't go like that though the
whole no no it's not just your neck it's
just the I don't have this I don't have
yeah I don't have that and also I I
don't have the strength to carry that
kind of weight no you it's just not made
for you yeah yeah you're not carrying
anybody you yeah but I could be like on
the outskirts the sniper no you watch on
the on the TV no no no no let me be the
guy on the outskirts like you guys go
get him not for you cuz you still got to
hike and carry a bunch of Lu no I can
hike just I don't want to carry a lot of
stuff just my gun just your gun or
better yet I have somebody carry that
[__] for me and I'm just super good at
shooting yeah you'd have to be real
special right yeah right yep you could
here give me my gun can you load it for
me because you don't know how to load it
and stuff well it's just like my fingers
get
cold like all that St my finger on the
trigger I was I was
tell hunting Partridge and I was like oh
my fing ah yeah so Brian can you do a
cold water challenge can we put you in
one of those tubs that's not that's not
a problem for me no I can do all that
who would last longer you Brendon no no
I can well he he did Ice bats also he's
built differently but I can do that
stuff that's not that I can I'll
surprise you with but also the the cold
plunge it's only like three minutes
right but I'll I'll surprise you it's
not that I I'll probably surprise you
with my endurance right so if you want
me to do burpees or I can kind of f
that's not a problem it like talking
snow days cold nights that's it now now
now you got me cold now you got me tired
I'm talking about even in my Prime not
56 I'm going to be I'm going to bend but
when I was even younger like I there was
a time where I did I tried to really do
all this CrossFit stuff to climb a rope
faster do Fran and I really pushed
myself and I did I did all right I
surprised myself did wrestling I had a
little bit of the mentality but it's
when you have to if when you when you
have to carry I was was in Afghanistan
and I put on an entire a Marine's entire
thing it was so [__] heavy 80 PB it's
just too heavy it's like 85 lbs I'm just
not I'm not strong that way I can
deadlift the most I've ever deadlift is
300 lb now I'm older that's terrible
it's not good come on it's not weak it's
not weak there's kids in high school
that do that well kids in high school do
500 lb yeah what I'm saying is that I'm
not there's things you can be built for
like dance and there are things you can
build for which is like carrying a lot
of [__] you just have to be built a
different way War yeah shut up there are
Fighters there are fighters who are
skinny and like you know that may not be
able to do it either you can be really
good at a sport in your weight class but
if when you're doing that guy like Dan
hooker the hangman he's super skinny
yeah that [__] can you could put
80 pounds on he's also a lot bigger than
you think he's tall he's about your
height I'm saying but but I'm saying Dan
is also on the off season when Dan's not
fighting he's he to 200 but he can still
get up to 200 he's a thinner kid but
he's still called the [__] hangman
for reason he's still thick though buba
he's still got M muscle he's still I
guarantee when he's not training like
when he's walking around he he gets
about 190 195 that's a lot of weight
comparatively well Nate Diaz long arms
big either right he's a skinny guy Nate
big I've hung with Nate so when I was
hanging out with Nate in San Diego Nate
was our definition of big is very
different buba he's 190 that's not a big
guy I know but it is I'm saying for you
compared to like like real [__] like
real like Brian comic smaller guy real
[__] 190 is nothing no that's what I'm
saying though it's you're not even the
ballpark bubble no but but I'm saying
250 260 lean but but 64 65 but there are
plenty of soldiers are 190 right so you
you still have to have a certain bone
structure like Nick Diaz I mean uh is is
is bigger than his brother he's still
Nick can be 200 when he walks around big
head you know big body not big no one
would look at him and say that's a big
guy no that's that's what I mean but
he's not small right he's just he's just
a guy he's not big he's not if I had to
fight with my weight I I would literally
have to think about fighting a 135 maybe
145 but probably 135 literally if my
with my frame sha Ali is my size really
yes Sean's like as tall as I am and
every bit is you know I mean you know
he's maybe a little thinner but barely
thin yeah and he sucks down to 1 135 but
again different no he's an athlete and
all that I'm saying physically there's a
just different thing I don't know that
you know it's it me mentally what
separates them mentally what separates
all these guys like you're not going to
break the Diaz's you're not going to
break that [__] special forces FR
there's nothing you can do in a fight
that those guys break it's impossible
Special Forces there's nothing you can
do to break them that's why when they
torture him they just kill him like all
right it's not happening you can't
there's there's no nothing you can do in
the world that these guys are going to
break Dan cormet doesn't break Jon Jones
doesn't break now there's guys who are
crazy talented and have almost that
mentality but then something happens in
a fight and they have one slip up and
they break so one of the things in the
seals but the the the the guys that go
on to become Champions unbreakable but
there there are things in the Seal
training some guys get hypothermia there
are guys that hypo out no matter what
they do they just have a constitution
that can't handle it so you can be tough
as [__] athletic [__] really strong you
have a certain kind of body you get you
get hypothermia they'll stick a
thermometer in your ass when remember
even those guys with hypothermia they'll
still can they don't break here they're
still down to go they have to pull the
the instructor has to pull them out yeah
they go they get delirious and they just
can't do the training so but again it
doesn't matter that's a Breaking Point
they even have another theory that's
really interesting about how like when
you're really tired right sometimes
you'll be in the jungle and a and a a
twiggle going in your eye or you'll you
you'll twist your ankle okay or you'll
get a you'll get a fracture all good
there's a good reason for it you stepped
on the wrong thing here's the here's the
here's the rub some people they they
have they're awake just a little bit
more than you are they they they're a
little bit more endur their endurance is
a little stronger so they can see that
twig for the last second they go like
that or they they see that thing and
they go oh I'm not going to turn I'm not
going to step there or or they don't get
a compound fracture why I don't know
they have stronger bones denser bones
who the [__] knows
you know so that's just the difference
it's really interesting so if he and I
are on a March he played football
forever he never got injured he just has
a different bone structure he's going to
be able to carry more weight he doesn't
get cold as easily he's going to be able
to carry [__] he's just gonna you know I
I could break him if he's really tired
maybe but everybody can break when
they're tired or whatever after nine
days or whatever but in the training
he's just not going to he's just not
going to break the way other guys do
physically he just doesn't my favorite
thing I used to love to see guys break
love it yeah wrestlers same way I'd
rather die before I stop yeah that's how
that that's Tony
Ferguson all of us have the same
mentality they'd rather when you go
about a CT what he'd rather go out on
his shield then go work at [__] Jiffy
Loop [__] I went to Dan Gable's
wrestling camp and they would train you
we train with the Hawkeyes and the whole
idea was to train you I couldn't
understand what they were doing to us
three days it was three days of training
three times a day and I was like this is
the worst [__] I was limping but the
idea was if we're going to overtrain you
to see if you can handle it and like
even in that camp a third of the camp
didn't graduate wow cuz it was just they
were just they were [__] torturing us
they we'd wake up at 5:30 I didn't know
what the [__] was going on the thing
they want put the resources in kids that
aren't built for that so it's not for
everybody it's a hard lesson for people
to
learn I learned it no I know you got it
I wrestled yeah all four years you did
the camp
welll it's good even for for my son with
baseball like there he was at a level
where he like all right everybody plays
you you know the Innings there's no
there's no you know mercy rule or there
are mercy rules like everyone plays it's
all good so he did that and then he
excelled there now he's on a travel
All-Star team then now it's like it's a
commitment so you know he had two games
all day Saturday we had practice Monday
through Friday then Sunday he had two
games and Sunday even I was like God
damn but I'm used to it so I'm just
driving no complaints I'm excited for
the game and then he's like oh this how
goes this how we do I'm like this what
we do dude I said I seven I said you
know what the rest of your friends are
doing he like go sleeping it where
they're at 6:00 a.m. throwing the ball
yeah because that's I'm used to it but
how do you how do you keep him from
burning out he does Sports he wants to
do it no he don't give wants to he wants
to do it he's out there happy as [__]
yep some kids love that [__] it's crazy
at seven to have that discipline though
well it's not discipline they just love
it but it's also good for him to see
like I'm not like oh man another game
Sunday oh hell no I'm crying for it hell
yeah you want to do do this dude let's
do it we're driving an hour you know
6:00 a.m. he loves it loves
it
yeah and there there's even kids on the
team like some of these kids are Savage
the way these kids are learning yeah now
SC there's also another kind of strength
there are different kinds of strength
different creative strengths some people
are way more you know a lot of comics
are [__] hilarious but they're they
fold like a chair most things yeah it
just depends on different strength
everybody's different that's it just
stay in your Lan when you can blend the
two you got Kevin Hart yeah yeah strong
mentally great work ethic hilarious
comic yeah
skyrockets that's what you get yep
that's how it goes
yep
Rogan there you go
Rogan that Rogan's a [__] Savage
Savage yep where oh oh I was in San
Diego doing stuff from my truck um the
guy was like your energy man cuz we got
there we left at 4:00 in the morning
then I have to shoot you know he's like
your energy how do you do it I was like
I didn't think about it it's just what
we do oh no it was great uh when I was
there at SPC they they were they were
talking about uh the owner of the club
and the other people were like man sha
he he's the nicest
guy and I was like I go yeah yeah yeah I
go no but he's so nice like you think
he'd be this big UFC guy kind of be he
was so nice to all of us he let us drink
his whiskey wasang I go that's Brendan
that's why we're really good that's why
he's my best friend we're not hanging
out because we're well there's another
reason I was like what a surprise Oh you
mean he treat wait you mean he treated
all of you really well yeah yeah that's
what Nick was like Nick Nick when you
left the room Nick Nick Simmons Nick's
crush his Clips are so good Nick goes
he's a [__] he calls his wife he goes
he's the [__] best guy he's such a
good guy guy a yeah yeah Nick's great
he's crushing it huh yeah he's doing
great he's [__] awesome yeah he's
like the next big thing his crush his
Clips are so good so funny so funny he's
the one guy I watch his clip he was
killing it this weekend he's getting
good [__] killing it I said to him I
said oh my God great work ethic and I
said to him stays in shape we work out
just [__] kills me on the gym he goes
um I said to him I go your job as my
feature is to have to look at me and say
good Lu can't do this anymore oh 100 I
got to go that's my the whole if you're
going to feature for me the idea is to
use me as a stepping stone I don't need
like he was waiting around on the last
show and I was like hey dude you can go
home you have an early flight don't wait
for me you don't work for me we work
together yeah he's like he's that guy
yeah same I've I've never had anybody
not open up for me then they don't
become to go Headliners I mean DAV Lucas
Chelle lost his dad when he lost his mom
when he was 17 and she had cancer for
eight years so he lived with that and he
was super close to her so he watched her
and his mother they took they gave his
mother 6 months to live and she goes I'm
going to watch my son graduate and she
did yeah he's a beast yeah why are you
so far behind him uh so I can look even
skinnier that's a weir pick somebody
took that though we were standing there
somebody said take
here
yeah gotta get on the old trt
photographer look natural me that's G be
bad shoes I have on huh oh those are
tough o you don't look bad that though
Bubba they're are those those have too
many stripes to be Adidas what are those
those are those are gay Swiss
oh oh my God those any I think you were
the one who were like I think you were
like you were like those are K Swiss and
I think I never wore them again I I
looked down I was like oh these are not
good shoes you know what you were doing
you hanging around the tennis guys yes
bunch of cucks no no no don't say that
sorry no no don't say that uh can I get
in your truck I'm not allowed still now
it's still no definitely not now yeah
not now huh not allowed in the truck not
allowed in the truck
um yeah we missed you on I could have
used joh on companion of
course you know Brad Bradley and ramp
Rampage is he's the best he's best we
talked a lot of Flat Earth cuz the
fights were a little boring we talked a
lot of Flat Earth and then you know
Rampage he's
not he doesn't watch UFC fights you know
like he's not into the UFC it's just you
know he he yeah Bradley does doesn't he
not really so it was like you know I
can't go too deep I yeah I called
Bradley uh two days ago three days ago
and I was like Bradley that guy Tom
havland that you know that guy that
Rogan talks about he's that impossibly
strong dude he only takes video from
behind him when he's lifting he had 720
caring that crazy [__] he's like 67 300
lb like there he is he's just an
absolute [__] monster all natural
totally natural oh my God RS daddy Bob
he's so strong it's weird like watch
what he does like you see what he does
and you're like how's he doing the
strong against the big boys that built
huh how do he do against so so I talk
you saying I called Brian Shaw I text
Brian Shaw I go Brian he was he was he
had 720 like this bub look like this and
he was squatting I said can you do that
serious question he goes he said
something like does the [__] does a bear
[__] in the wood yeah he can [__] do
that but he said but he goes but I have
to but right now I'm training for
fighting he goes I'd have to train for
that like I just it's how he how's he
stack up against like the Brian Shaws
and the Thors not as strong not as
strong it's not as you don't realize how
strong those guys are oh my God it's
stupid but he's respected I mean you
know it's like [__] yeah he's respected
crazy how strong he look at him but
that's a crazy body 67 I'm proud of him
look at his back I mean he's doing crazy
[__] he's doing crazy [__] it's cool to
see and he's somewhere out in the middle
of like Australia he's just out there
doing crazy he
is it was funny Rampage saying cuz
Rampage does look good and Bradley look
good all of us like we all look good
right and uh Bradley's like God Rampage
what you been doing this new trainer man
blah blah blah BR training Go in all
natural Bradley he's
not Rampage was so pissed I come on
rampage I said how old is he was 42 and
then and then uh Bradley goes yeah yeah
cuz 42 it's so normal to look that
jacked and shredded and then but I I get
I didn't want to go bad on his training
so I said I said there he is that's him
he goes he's all natural and I said
there is guys who are freaks he might be
one of the that's why I said I know a
few guys Tim too Joe Clavin they can eat
whatever they want and they just it's
just their genetics who is that guy
that's his trainer well he's fantastic
why is he not running for president what
a fantastic head of hair oh he's Fant
well he's fantastic well you know what
he is he's fantastic in general and he
should always wear that outfit oh um
dude he's taking that a and he's taking
these there's no joking around here this
is all serious and that is as natural as
you get but with a with with like a if
he had a strict that's what Rampage says
has like the strictest diet you could
get there I don't know how height and
weight Bradley said absolutely not but I
disagree I know some freaks there are
some freaks there's some freaks he might
be one of them like um DJ medcafe I was
looking at his body like that's that's
that guy's just a freak of freaks the
difference is he's like all pro receiver
this guy right but the freaks are out
there as long the freaks are out there
yeah genetically they're they're out
there like that guy yeah that's a better
body than I
have yeah when you can sport a crop top
as a man you know you're you're doing
something right yeah yeah he's a freak
yeah he's so talented yeah he's 1.6 body
fat that's a lie that's all right though
what's that 1. what yeah that's not real
1.6 body fat that's on a that's dumb
like when Ronnie Coleman came on Rogan
was like how was that 2% body F it's not
you actually know a lot about about
stuff like that yeah you do actually
know a lot about nutrition and [__] yeah
literally impossible cuz you always call
out you're always like no I don't think
so like that cryo thing I remember click
[__] it's like not you were saying
nothing about the cryo and I was like
and you were like it's not going to last
I was I've also been in it like my boy
Klo was shredded in college and we all
did our body fat and he was like 12%
yeah that's all that's very low that's
so lean yeah so when they say 1.6 I'm
like no that's not and you do it by
lowering you lower in water and you do
this they had that see they had
everything they this egg thing they had
the calibers they had the NFL come and
do it so I see shredded black dudes
they'd be like at the most 9% shreded so
1.6 coming that's dumb it's fun for
clicks yeah yeah he's probably low as
[__] but that's not real no but but
Rampage was always super muscular he's a
naturally very thick muscular guy so
he's looks so much better and 42 still
you still got stuff going on he had
carbs him forever yeah yeah but he
looked though he looked great yeah he's
trying to get a fight with Lennox Lewis
I didn't know he wasn't retired he told
me he's like yeah no I'm not
retired LX Lewis
boxing okay like some Legend fight but
but Saudi money that's great saud's
going to enjoy that enjoy that with
lanx um I don't know what L's been doing
but yeah all right Jim what do you got
uh you guys talking about bodies so
there's this
kid I get find him
here Jes Walt I don't know how to say
his name wal Tei wesy champ so
apparently that's him in high school
he's like 17 now I think oh my god
oh well some people are just made to to
run through people or just do sport on a
high level he looks like mac he looks
like Mac from [__] the San Diego
Chargers yeah actually he's a teenager I
mean these were pictures from when he I
think he was 16 I think he's 17 now or
something I lik it like that though it's
just but every so quick your steroids
that's fake like I no I knew a kid in
high school like that I
didn't that [__] big in the 70s yeah
no not the 70s also also in the ' 80s
please be respectful I didn't know D I'm
spit ideas I don't you to be respectful
I don't the timeline God damn it that
dude is Jack that is so [__] insane
it's always weird though because people
think cuz he's that Jack he's going be a
superstar he gets to college and you're
like oh all the linebackers look like
this yes yeah some kids PE ear right
yeah yeah you don't want a mustache in
high school it's never a good sign he
has a full goatee beard like that's
never a good sign yeah you don't want a
peak in high school yeah the good days
are still ahead buddy he's probably a
freak
though all right uh have you heard about
this Boston mayor Michelle woo yeah so
her uh someone from her team sent out
this email I guess it's a annual H
annual party where it's
called something about like for Co color
or something party Only For Colored
elected officials of color that's what
it's called and they so they have um six
minorities and seven white members in
can you see where she went to school
yeah this is what's happening in school
oh let me see it Boston City CC
comprised of six minority and seven
white members who are not intended
targets of the email so they had to
email back saying for the white people
sorry it was a mistake to send to invite
you guys so it's like this did they
throw all white party and that's okay
that's what I'm saying like if I'm a
white guy they I'm like okay I guess
we'll throw a white party no pun
intended so it's like Reverse Racism
basically and um yeah do this every year
looks like some white people there well
I mean she's probably like Latina or
something she's like first nation or
something indigenous something like that
yeah like okay so the white people don't
get a party because it's hilarious their
life is a party it's
hilarious white people
get hold on let's see I cordially invite
you and a guest electeds of color
holiday party how do you think that
makes the white people feel man yeah not
anybody gives a [__] this day and age
but so okay my thing is okay if you guys
can do that is it a race if I throw an
only white party you know what [__] I
would get yeah but why how's it any
different it's not if they don't have a
Christmas party and the whites are like
all right I guess we just thr our party
same party every year but we called the
white party you know we and when I went
to I went to boarding school in
Massachusetts and they had these things
where they would have only like they'd
have a get together of people of color
and stuff this was going on in the
liberal uh schools uh here's my thing I
don't have a problem with it my problem
is all right you have the whatever the
black's only party Mexicans only party
do your thing but don't give me [__] for
having a white only party and it's going
to be way more lit don't don't be mad
how's it any different than what you
guys are doing well the you guys always
have the idea yeah the idea is that
always white parties but if you want to
name yours I to name mine yeah
but you got to remember that that there
is we won't call it the white party we
call the awesome people only party 70%
of Young Americans ped I think under 25
or under 24 consider the United States
an oppressor
Nation because that's what they're told
yeah that's what they're taught that's
older people back to the elephants
killing each other you need older
elephants go no no no this is they're
going to tell you we have all these
problems go to Ukraine go to Gaza go to
Africa you want to see problems try
being gay in Brazil let me not goes for
you we're actually safe here but they
want us fighting for a reason that's
right that's right Matthew Perry doing
ketamine uhhuh they said he had enough
ketamine in his system it was like he
was getting a operation yeah anesthesia
but I read he was doing ketamine therapy
for six weeks and then stopped but do
you do that heavy of of a dose when
you're in therapy I don't know I I have
friends who did King therapy and it
worked for him he had everything in the
world and he just uh he had suffered
from I guess depression of some said he
smoked two pack a day too yeah he was
trying to kill himself he was trying to
get off of it and then they then they
said he was on trt and it gave him
horrible outrages like all right come on
I've seen nothing but I see this you
know being in this town for so long I'm
always amazed at how dysfunctional some
very famous people can be you're just
like what the [__] is going on but
sometimes what drives them that deep
insecurity makes them really good at
acting they're fragile fragile creatures
it goes back to what we were talking
about not going to be a Navy SEAL but
you'll be a hell of an actor you know
so um the amount of
drugs I went to my friend well he was my
friend I knew him through other people
so I'm not call but Ted Demi who was a
famous director and he did the ref he
did a lot of great movies he did um blow
remember blow one my favorite movies
great movie and Teddy died of uh cocaine
he he was doing blow all night and
played was playing pickup basketball and
just died right on the court at 37 years
old and I went to the I went to the
funeral and it was a who's who Johnny
Depp spoke everybody spoke and man oh
man I couldn't believe the amount of
drugs and alcohol that they all had
stories about doing drugs and alcohol
that's all they did it was just I was
like that's how they related huh that's
how they they were in the band together
that's it everybody did a lot of that
stuff all the time wow that's a bummer
so yeah he El Jan uh sinos not this one
sorry we already did this video covered
it this one okay oh wow the this I I
mean there's no words for it it's in the
middle of a selfie and look at this
Trooper just getting the footage for us
it's a real content creator this
huh oh she thought this was going to be
a good time she's having a look at
her between oh she's about to
drown Jesus Christ it's a tsunami not
good yeah yeah that's not good that's a
flash flood I don't think it's a tsunami
it's called a flash flood yeah she she
could have been drowned so easily 100%
that's a flash flood espe under like a
people die in flash floods all the
[__] time that's what that looks
probably not from doing selfies what now
I know you guys like crocodiles oh boy
love
them it's music so I can't play it look
at this
guy don't be a dummy what's he ey on yes
oh oh that they do oh it's on the KN
they have the strongest bite
too he must be on drugs then no I mean
first his hand then his leg dumbass yeah
you that's a small that's on the top of
his kneecap yeah that's got to feel good
oh my God that thing will shake your
knee right off what do you think you do
in that situation you punch it
apparently his leg was read
more
ah yeah yeah that's not a Croc is it
it's an alligator yeah yeah what's the
difference snout well alligator's GNA be
wider Crocs going to be skinnier yeah
and and a crocod CR way more aggressive
come on come on man wow yeah you you
[__] with a Nile Croc oh good luck your
food that game's over they're coming for
you they're not they're not doing that
they're coming for you you're not you're
not scared of an alligator though I mean
I would [__] with it like this but I'm
way more scared of a saltwater croc yeah
saltwater croc wants you that's nothing
to play with wants you
there's that there's that video of that
guy he thought he was a shaman and uh
he's in Indonesia and he like my magic
will protect me no and he gets into that
super murky water it's great video and
uh he's he's doing this on the water and
he's
swimming and he gets to the ladder and
uh well he gets pulled under and you can
see him under the water doing this
looking down trying to get the Croc and
then he disappears disappears and not
only does he disappear uh then you see
the Croc swimming with his like a it's a
18t Croc with the guy's body in his
mouth just swimming easy day at work for
the CR easy day at work man it's like oh
dude you got drowned right quick now
probably went pretty quick but bad
that's going to happen bad way to go
that's going to happen there's another
special with the guys the two cops are
patrolling the river they're in
Indonesia there's a fisherman his boat's
here and he's in the water up to about
here and he's he's untangling his net
and the the cop goes he's Brave he's
Brave in Indonesian right and uh well
they came back and he
disappeared and they found him in the
belly of a 16t Croc that's what happens
don't get in the water cuz you're food
there's dinosaurs dinosaur
dinosaurs what else you got Jen oh the
other one kind of suck it's all right
don't be so hard on yourself would you
guys shark dive would you do that thing
yeah I do the great only only well only
great white he's never done great white
he get black tip doesn't count I I don't
I don't understand why people want to do
that oh I would love to see a great
white they're magical I love
them um did we play this last week I
don't think we did right what is this
this is in San Diego yeah I saw this
okay I thought we saw this right I
wonder if we saw it on the side or
something but Dominic Cruz like cops
body language so zero confidence and no
hand to hand defense defense all that's
the cop like runs right you looks like
guys know other guy knows how to party
[__] so he's tasing him right here it's
not working oh hell no well you worry
he's going to bite you your something is
he high on something he's got to be of
course I might have shot
him I like how he's like all right I've
had my fun I'm going get back in my
truck he did take off but they did get
him afterwards
[__] oh [__] wow um a big thing that
happened here is like a lot of it became
a race thing a lot of people were saying
like imagine if he was black he would be
dead like that was like the majority a
bunch of the comments I don't think that
guy was going to shoot that guy no
matter what color the cop yeah guy was
like he realized the guy was just
totally crazy of course people made it
about Rays yeah CU that cop was Latino
or Asian wasn't white wasn't black no
that's another Point
yeah yeah but yeah but Dominick Cruz is
right that cop did not look like he was
very cops by language show zero
confidence self no hand to hand
self-defense at all this accidents
happen other guy knows how to party he's
right yeah [__] Dominic was showing
me crazy nasty [__] just with your wrist
I was like ah [__]
yeah what else you got Jen um I mean is
this interesting at all yeah zuer what's
he know that we don't this is what
should make you alarm $100 million
compound in Hawaii with like a big
bunker
yeah what's he know we don't what are
you getting ready for now quick question
did he buy this on the same land where
they had the fire
conspiracy house at least three bedrooms
complete with underground bunker with
his own food and energy energy sources
it's got a lot of guest houses and stuff
he's creating a commune I do
it houseful 30 bedroom 30 B 30 bathrooms
yeah that place can be lit yeah I will
be group of 11 disc-shaped tree houses
joined together by rope Bridges sounds
so fun that's exactly how I spend my
money so [__] fun and it's like built
in the mountain like [__] the Mr evil
of Austin Powers that's pretty awesome
that's sick and bro they'd have
Jiu-Jitsu mats we can train NOP NOP nope
no a little bit the underground the
underground bunker is weird I know if we
have a ring do some training no I just
want the underground bunker not going to
fist bump him nope which is MMA training
[__] so this is something I saw after
the fights last night neon is a streamer
that's been on Bradley Martin's stream a
whole bunch he's a very nerdy looking
kid but apparently he said something
that he was going to confront Donald
Trump so Dana White made sure that he
got denied at the doors yeah he didn't
get in
yeah and he said he was baned from The
Arena tonight specifically by he said he
was B from Thea no what happened is he
he said some stupid [__] on Instagram
and uh you know he he bought tickets so
he wasn't anywhere close when you start
saying stupid [__] like that yeah you're
probably going to get busted up and
thrown out of here you know making
threats and talking dumb [__] looking
for clout I believe he said he was going
to I don't care what he said I think he
said he was going to confront Donald
Trump care what he said did he well he
wasn't able to he's just [__] tall
too you know
that [__] punk there's a popular
streamer online called NE yeah it's Dana
White's
party it's his white
party that kid was going to go you know
confront Donald Trump so they made sure
he didn't get in but again the Stream
they're all there you know it's all
influence yeah do whatever you can and
get
clicks what these kids do well we did it
again buddy we did it again budy we did
it again we did it again did it again we
did it again D Town comes out this week
it's all on the Ford Lightning the
problems I'm having with the Ford
Lightning it's a good one I think we Dro
is that the guy who's GNA yeah that's
the guy okay um Good Luck into Donald
Trump yeah I'll see y'all uh this
weekend off the hook Comedy Club at
Naples come get some and then I got uh
Comedy Zone Charlotte North for New Year
yeah New Year's uh December 29 30 and 31
two shows on New Year's yeah yeah it
should be fun Thursday Friday Saturday
Sunday as well well it's the 31st so
I'll ring in the New Year all right kids
I'm off the road till January 25th
Nashville one night only then two nights
in Austin Texas January 26 27th that's
it kids we will see you happy holidays
we will see you guys Wednesday though so
this isn't the last one Wednesday is our
last one for the holidays all right kids
love you we're out